[ Cheers and applause ]
-From Studio 6B
in Rockefeller Center
in the heart of New York City,
it's "The Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon."
♪♪
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
-Tonight,
join Jimmy and his guests --
Kit Harington...
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
-...Tyler James Williams...
and featuring
Paul Shaffer and
the World's Most Dangerous Band.
♪♪
-Hey, am I in the right studio?
[ Finale plays ]
-And now here he is...
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
-...Jimmy Fallon!
-Let them know now!
-♪ Hey, hey, hey ♪
-Oh, man!
-♪ Heeeeey ♪
[ Music ends ]
-Paul! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes! Yes!
That's exactly what
I'm talking about, right there.
Come on, now!
Oh, yes!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo! What a night!
Paul Shaffer, right there,
ladies and gentlemen.
Welcome the Most Dangerous Band.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jimmy Fallon.
-Enjoy yourselves.
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're here.
This is "The Tonight Show."
Be honest --
how many of you were clapping
just to get the feeling
back in your hands?
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ] This weekend,
the Northeast could be hit
with the coldest weather
in decades,
with temperatures dropping
as low as minus 40 degrees.
[ Audience ohhs ]
Yeah.
It is so cold that
President Biden's
burning classified documents
just to stay warm.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
It is so cold, Tom Brady
came out of retirement
just to huddle with the guys.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
♪♪
It is so cold,
everyone looks like
they're in "Avatar" -- everyone.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
It is --
[ Laughter ]
There's a few more of these.
It is so cold, even
Prince William and Harry's
relationship feels warm.
[ Audience oohs ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think
there's two or three more.
-Oh, what?
[ Laughter ]
-It is so -- Do you understand
how cold it is?
-How cold is it?
-It is so cold,
on Spirit Airlines,
they made all the passengers
roll up their window.
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
♪♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean,
it is freezing out there.
-I didn't understand that
till now.
-It is so cold,
the Empire State Building
is six inches shorter
than normal.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Applause ]
This is the final one
right here.
-All right.
-It is so cold --
It is so cold...
-How cold is it?
-It is so cold, George Santos
claimed it was hot.
That's...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Clicks tongue ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks.
Meanwhile, a reporter
in New Jersey
was asking people how they are
dealing with the cold weather,
and one guy had a pretty
unexpected response.
Watch this.
-This weekend, the cold --
how are you going to handle it?
What's the plan?
-I don't know.
I work in a freezer, so it's not
that big of a deal for me.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
-Looks more like
he's been locked in a freezer.
Yeah, it's like, hey...
[ Laughter ]
In New Jersey,
he's working in a freezer.
That sounds like something
the mob would say.
"Vinny?
Oh, let's just say he's, uh,
[sniffs]
working in a freezer."
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys,
everyone's talking about this.
U.S. officials spotted
what they say
is a massive Chinese spy balloon
flying over Montana.
Yeah, the spying is scary,
but the balloon part
makes it kind of cute.
Right?
[ Laughter ]
It's like Putin saying,
"I'm hiding in my
underground bouncy house."
[ Laughter ]
That's right --
officials said the balloon
was recently spotted
flying over Montana.
Well, let's check in
on the balloon right now.
Let me see.
[ Wind rushing ]
Oh, that's the spy balloon
there.
Oh, hey, wait, oh.
[ Wind rushing ]
[ Gunshot ]
There you go -- he took...
That's it right there.
"Yellowstone."
He takes care of it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, switching gears,
some entertainment news --
this Sunday is
the 65th annual Grammy Awards.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-65 years.
The Grammys are so old,
they're starting to not know
the performers at the Grammys.
[ Laughter ]
"Who's Bad Bunny?"
You can watch the Grammys
on CBS and Paramount+.
In other words, you'll be
watching the Grammys on CBS.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
Tickets to Beyoncé's tour
go on sale Monday.
And Ticketmaster said
that demand is already 800%
higher than what's available.
Today, the Ticketmaster CEO
showed up to congress like,
"Let's just get these hearings
out of the way.
Let's just do it."
[ Laughter ]
It'll be fun on Monday
when the CEO's
rocking back and forth
and mumbling,
"You just broke my soul.
You just broke my soul."
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this --
Amazon said that some customers
are now able to get their
delivery orders within hours.
Yeah, it's crazy.
Now when you drunk-order stuff,
it shows up,
you're still drunk.
[ Laughter ]
"Cool, I wanted this."
"Finally."
And finally,
a new $10 million sculpture
was just unveiled
in New York City.
Take a look at this thing.
Yeah, I don't know.
It doesn't look like
a work of art.
It looks like a Chinese spy
balloon going into Starbucks.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We have a great show tonight.
Give it up for
for Paul Shaffer and
the World's Most Dangerous Band!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Music ends ]
Come on, now!
Come on.
-And you know that.
-Come on, now.
-Come on.
-That's what I'm talking about.
Paul Shaffer, right there.
-Thank you, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The World's Most Dangerous Band.
-What a trip.
This is surreal to be here
after all this time.
-I'm so excited that you're here
and thankful that you're here.
But this is --
when was the first time?
This has been -- What?
-Well, you know,
this is such a coincidence
that we're here tonight,
because 41 years ago,
this very week,
was when David Letterman
came on the air right here,
right across the hall
here at NBC --
-Is that right?
-...with "The Late Show
with David Letterman."
-Oh, my gosh.
-So, this is, like,
our 41st anniversary
that we're celebrating.
And thanks to you,
I have reunited the entire band
from "The Letterman Show."
We're all here.
-Yes! That's what
I'm talking about.
Come on!
-All the favorites...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-...boys and girl.
And we're just having the time
of our lives, thanks to you.
-When -- When he -- When
David Letterman first started,
he started
as a morning show, right?
-That's right, yes, yes.
-And he asked you
to be the musical director?
-I got the call from him to do
"The Morning Show."
It was right after
"Saturday Night --"
I had done the first
five seasons
of "Saturday Night Live"...
-That's right.
-...as a pianist and a little
bit of performing and writing.
-Yeah.
-And then, right, I got a call.
"David Letterman is going
on the air
at 10:00 in the morning, live."
And I -- I turned it down.
I turned him down.
-You turned it down?
-I did.
-Why? Why?
-Couldn't get up that early.
[ Laughter ]
But no --
-Why yeah, of course.
-It just didn't seem --
I don't know, you know?
But luckily for me,
when that show didn't happen,
they gave him another shot.
They gave him "The Late Show,"
the 12:30 spot.
-Yeah.
And they called me again.
And this time, I had
the sense enough to say yes.
And, you know,
here we are, 33 years later,
between the two networks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We were all together.
Yeah.
-You know what's --
I would have thought --
I thought about you,
and I was so happy.
But when I used to do
"Letterman" --
First of all, I was a big fan.
I watched his show.
I watched "Late Night"
all the time.
And I love David Letterman --
he's a genius, so funny.
But I remember,
when I did the show,
I would be nervous to meet you.
-Ah!
-Because, yeah.
I mean, I'm such a fan.
And I was, like,
so nervous to be around you
and meet you guys and watch you.
But you not only changed
the game and raised the bar
of what a band
can do on the show --
obviously, Doc Severinsen --
but then, you showed us
how to do --
take it to a next level.
And then I think you changed
the face of comedy as well,
if I may say, because you would
laugh at a joke when --
You told me backstage,
by the way,
for the first two episodes,
they didn't turn your mic on.
-Well, that's another story.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-But when they turned your mic
on and Dave told a joke,
and sometimes the audience
wouldn't really laugh.
But you would go, "Ah."
[ Laughter ]
And that's when you knew
it was funny.
And comedy nerds around at home
are going,
"He's right --
that was a funny joke,
and the audience
just didn't get it yet."
And you guys went, "Ah."
[ Laughter ]
-I didn't know I had
that much responsibility,
but I'm thrilled to hear it,
though.
-No. Now, I think,
because of you,
comedians everywhere,
comedians I know,
they all laugh like you.
-Oh, is that right?
-Every comedian --
Tina Fey laughs like you.
-Ah.
-You see a funny joke,
you go, "Ah."
-Ah.
-That's you.
-Ah. Ah.
-They're doing you.
That's Paul Shaffer right there,
ladies and gentlemen.
I'm honored -- honored!
-I am humbled.
Jimmy, I am humbled. I can't --
-Be honor--
Beyond honored that you're here.
-Well, you know, remember,
I mean, all of us
look to Johnny Carson
as our model.
And he used to have
Doc Severinsen at band leader
and Ed on the panel to talk to.
And I used to say, "I'm
a combination of Doc and Ed."
In other words, I'm "Ded."
[ Laughter ]
Basically, I'm "Ded."
-That's exactly right, yeah.
-But I'm alive tonight.
-[ Laughs ] Come on.
I'm happy you're here, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
♪♪
Well, what a show.
What a show
we have for you tonight.
He stars in the new film
"Baby Ruby,"
which is in theaters
and on demand now.
Kit Harington is here tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Plus, he just won a Golden Globe
for his role on the hit series
"Abbott Elementary,"
which airs Wednesdays on ABC.
Tyler James Williams is here
tonight, too!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
And it's -- And it's Friday.
-Friday.
-Today's Friday,
and that's usually when I catch
up with some personal stuff.
I check my inbox.
I return some emails.
And, of course,
send out thank-you notes.
And I was just running...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...running a bit behind.
So, I thought if you guys
wouldn't mind, can I write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now for you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Paul -- Paul, could I get some
"thank-you note writing" music?
-Yes, here it is, yeah.
[ Somber music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-So somber.
-It's so fun.
-This is so fun --
just seeing this
and hearing this.
I'm having the greatest time
right now.
[ Breathes sharply ]
♪♪
Thank you, Beyoncé Tour,
for making my newest hobby
refreshing Ticketmaster.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, cocktail sauce,
for being an overly elegant name
for something that's 90% Heinz.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's like, "Cocktail sauce?"
-Ooh-la-la!
-[ Chuckles ]
-Mmm! Catsup.
♪♪
Thank you, massive Chinese
spy balloon over Montana.
I can't wait to see you
in this year's
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade.
That's going to be --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey!
Whoa!
[ Chuckles ]
-Coming down 5th Ave.
♪♪
Thank you, snow mobiles,
for looking like
a Transformer planking.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Netflix
cracking down on shared logins,
for severing our last tie
to our college roommate.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's it.
Now we're done.
Goodbye.
Out of my life.
-Yeah.
Never going to see them again.
-Out of my life.
♪♪
Thank you, puffy coats,
for giving me full-body abs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I've got a 20-pack.
♪♪
-I got a washing machine.
-I got a 25-pack.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, Paul Shaffer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When people -- When people talk
about legends on late-night TV,
you're number one
on everyone's Top Ten List.
There you have it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Those were our thank-you notes.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody!
Come on back!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ 3,000 ♪